[Music]
so first a bit about who we are who your
presenters are here so my name is Eliot
I'm an engineer on the bigquery team I'm
also a tech Phyllida manager
my specialty is sequel so I'm not the
star of the show though honestly I'm
joined here by super from the Home Depot
and if you're gonna listen to any of it
listen to what he's saying cuz he's
gonna talk about data management at Home
Depot and you'll get a lot of sort of
real-life experience about about what
Home Depot actually does so thank you
all for coming and I hope it's a good
session so the first thing I want to
talk about was this topic of big
metadata everybody throws around the
term big data which is cool in itself
right bigquery excels a processing huge
volumes of data but the thing that I
want to talk about here is actually the
data around that data or as I like to
call it big metadata in this case so for
a bit of an overview big queries
architecture looks something like this
there's a lot of pieces I omitted but
you can generally think of the system as
being roughly this shape so we have
things here like you know you can get
data in through streaming addition
there's bulk loading we have this data
transfer service where you can get data
and I didn't even picture here we have
interfaces like the UI we have client
libraries etc some of the cool pieces
behind the scenes are things like our
high available compute cluster this is
where we actually run the queries that
you that you give to us we have our
storage system and then what ties this
all together is this really fast network
that the Google build it's hard to
imagine building the system anywhere
else just because we have such a great
infrastructure that makes this possible
so the thing that I want to focus on
today is the the data that we actually
manage behind the scenes for you and
what goes into that so I wanted to start
by talking about what makes the table so
we've got a variety of attributes to the
table right so there's things like the
table ID itself this is like the name of
it so to speak we have the schema of the
table various attributes like whether
it's partitioned what partition and
column there is whether it's clustered
that sort of thing we have the amount of
data that is being stored so the number
of bytes the number of rows that kind of
thing we have the description of the
table you can edit this yourself for
example and then we have the actual data
itself so
so that's great but what really makes
the table like what is the actual
representation behind the scenes of
tables in bigquery so we use this format
that we call capacitor there's a great
blog post about this actually I don't
have enough time to go into the details
of this but capacitor is a format that
lets us really efficiently represent
nested and repeated data and this is
what we use in bigquery we develop this
format herself this is sort of a secret
sauce so to speak a bigquery that makes
Corey's really fast so we store this
data for you in this format and when we
store these capacitor files all of these
are encrypted arrests they're durable
meaning that if one copy of a file on a
disk ends up getting deleted or there's
a problem with the hardware and that
kind of thing we're not going to lose it
right it's also highly available so if
part of a data center is not operational
we're able to still survey that data and
there's no there's no chance of it being
lost essentially okay so the thing that
we do is that we have this this this
concept that builds on these files
called storage sets so storage sets are
a grouping of these capacitor files and
a storage set is a combination of a few
things so it's it's a path of the files
in our distributed storage it has a
partition key for partition tables it
has a timestamp of when we actually
committed this data when we wrote it to
our to our metadata
it has a UUID so some unique identifier
for that for that storage set and then
it has a variety of stats so this
includes things like column sizes for
example so when you run a query against
the table we fetch these column sizes
from these storage sets to figure out
how much data will actually be scanned
as part of that query then it has a
state so it can be in a pending state it
can be committed or it can be in a
garbage state meaning that it was
deleted or is no longer applicable so
they give you a sense of scale of this
we have on the order of billions of
storage that's in bigquery I just ran a
query last night this is a current
snapshot of the system right so this
tends to change over time but currently
it's on that we're of on the order of
billions so that's a lot of metadata
right so why did we do this why do we
have these stored sets in bigquery well
the reason that we do this is it's the
unit of atomicity and what I mean by
that is that it gives us properties like
this so when I select from a table as at
a particular time stamp what it means is
that I ignore any storage sets that are
pending or garbage state I only read the
ones that were committed as of that time
staff of which I'm reading the data if
they weren't committed at that point if
they were committed later then I ignore
them so when we perform operations like
loading data or DML queries all that
sort of thing all these operations
either succeed or they don't and when
you run a query you never see partially
written data so the property that we
provide is known as snapshot isolation
basically never had to worry that when
you run a query that you'll see the
partial state of the table because we
have this unit of atomicity called
storage sets when we persist that data
either you're seeing all of it or you're
not so it creates storage sets so when
you load data into the system we create
a storage set per partition or when you
stream data in what we do is we actually
buffer that data that you're sending us
and then periodically flush this data
into our into our managed storage when
you run a query tables select statement
we're actually taking the results of
that query and writing it to storage
sets behind the scenes or when you run
DML statements update insert etc were
creating a storage sets as well as part
of those operations so let's look at how
this works in practice imagine I had
this query where I'm selecting from a
table so I'm selecting these couple of
columns x and y from this table here so
what do we do first wait what we do is
we list the storage sets in our spanner
metadata we use spanner spanner is
awesome this is how we keep track of all
of our metadata behind the scenes so we
list the storage sense with these tables
from our spanner metadata and then we
send a request to our query engine that
describes the mapping of these tables to
these storage sets that we're going to
read this part of the query as sort of a
brief architecture there's a lot of
pieces missing here but you can roughly
think of it like this so as a client you
send a request with a query to bigquery
there's a couple of steps here we have
this router behind the scenes that
figures out where to actually send the
query when we receive it it goes to this
job server we have these spanner tables
for job metadata a table metadata etc
and what we're doing is we're looking up
data for the tables dereference and then
we use that as part of execution in our
query engine itself and you can see down
here so we have our distributed storage
system with capacitor files they're
actually on disk and when we go to read
a table what we're doing is we're
reading the capacitor files relevant to
that particular table this
referenced here so this worked for
partition tables though so for partition
tables we actually have one or more
storage sets for each day for which you
have data so in this example I have data
for the seventh the eighth the tenth and
so on and so I can have one or more
storage sets for each of those days
storage sets can span partitions so what
happens when I run a query is that when
I select from a partition table I match
any of the storage sets for the days
that are referenced so in this example
I'm selecting data for the tenth so what
I do is that as bigquery when I'm
fetching the storage sets relevant to
the query at hand I filter out the ones
outside of the tenth year so because I
had this filter where I restricted the
data I was reading to the tenth it means
I could ignore any storage sets outside
of that so you may be familiar with the
concept of clustering and big who are
you what clustering lets you do is
actually layout the data in your tables
according to some clustering keys and
when you do this what happens is that
we're actually laying out the files
based on the clustering cues you
provided us so these storage set files
are sorted by the cluster keys
essentially so what happens in this case
so when you select from a from a table
that's both partitioned and clustered
and you have a query that looks like
this so I'm restricting the date that
I'm reading to the 10th year and then
I'm restricting further that the price
is between these two different values so
if my table was clustered by price what
I would do is that first I would apply
that that date filter that you gave me
so I'd restrict the data being read to
the tenth right and then further what I
can do is because you gave me this
filter on this price column I can filter
out more of the data behind the scenes
and then this is passed along in terms
of reduced query time and also a lower
query cost for the query itself ok
so that was sort of on selecting from a
table right but what happens when I
actually update a table so when I go and
update a partitioned table what we do is
we list the stored sets that match
whatever filter you gave us if any so in
this case I have this filter on the 8th
or the 10th and then what I do is I run
a query and I actually rewrite the
active storage sets for this query so
what this looks like is that in this
case I've restricted the data being
modified to these particular storage
that's here based on that filter that
you gave me and then what I end up doing
is I decide that okay based on this
running this query I end up modifying
these storage sets and then I replace
these essentially and mark the old ones
this being and now a garbage date and
now I have this new data that I've
committed for this table and again all
this is atomic right so if somebody else
is running a query the same time they're
not going to see the partially modified
state of the storage while woodson
translated so we also allow simultaneous
updates on partition tables I can
actually have two updates running at the
same time that modify different dates
within this table so this example I have
a query that's modifying both the 9th
and and the 10th here are sorry they ate
them at 10th and then I have another one
that's modifying the 7th these were ok
as long as they don't have conflicts
between them so I have one query that
goes and rewrites the storage sets for
the 8th in the 10th and then one that's
modifying the 7th and there's no
conflict because the the queries are
reading and modifying storage sets and
different partitions as part of this so
we also provide this really cool feature
I think called time travel so the notion
of time travel is that because we have
these storage sets that we're keeping
for your tables we let you travel back
in time and see the historical version
of a table as it was up to 7 days in the
past so we have these storage sets that
we're keeping right when you go and run
a query and add data for example we're
committing new storage sets what you can
do is that when you run this this query
with this clause that says for system
time as of some timestamp we can go and
fetch the storage sets that we're going
to come into the state as of that
timestamp and that means that you can
read the data as it was prior to a load
job or prior to some DML query for
example so if you run a query and you
realize oops I deleted all the rows in
my table I'd really like to you know get
that data back you can go and use this
feature called time travel and use this
clause to actually read that data as it
was before you made that operation
so we're can this go wrong how can they
store it set send it in a bad state or
are things just always happy so storage
sets can end up in a bad state for a
couple different reasons so you end up
with a really large number of very small
storage
end up having essentially way more
metadata than you do data if you do
things like micro batch your load job so
if you load really small files like
let's say one every minute and only has
a few rows at a time what ends up
happening is that we we have essentially
more meditative than we do data for that
table so you can also do things like
stream at really low QPS so if you're
streaming like one row every minute what
we end up doing is when we flush that
data we're writing very small storage
sets periodically to that table or if
you perform very small dno queries at
least for now so this is sort of a
snapshot in time right so the way the
DML works currently is that we're
committing a storage set for each of the
DML queries we perform I say this is a
snapshot in time because this is subject
to change in the future ok so what's the
actual symptom of this well for one
thing korie's can take a long time to
fetch metadata before executing I
mentioned that we do that read from
spanner of all that those towards that's
right so if you have let's say one per
minute that you were creating as part of
these loads we can end up with more than
a thousand storage sets over the course
of a day and so we have to go and fetch
all of those which includes things like
the column sizes and so on it's a lot to
actually fit in memory and pass through
on the system and so your queries can
actually end up taking a bit longer than
you'd expect even though it may be
processing a small amount of data or
because we use the number of files and
storage sets for example as a hint for
parallelism we can end up using more
workers to try to process your data than
we would normally do so what can you do
instead well as you may have guessed you
can perform less frequent larger load
jobs so we provide the ability to
specify a glob pattern and you can load
a bunch of data at a time by matching a
pattern that's on cloud storage for
example or you can stream it a hierarchy
PS basically use the right API for the
job so if you have a lot of data that's
fooling it continuously over time you
probably want to use the streaming API
rather than a load API on the flipside
if you have data that's arriving very
infrequently in sort of larger batches
use the use the load API or execute
larger DML queries so if you have a lot
of rows that you want to modify instead
of running ten DML queries for example
just run one that modifies all of them
in one pass but even if you don't
there's a silver lining
so bigquery manages your data for you
and what I mean by this is that if even
if you have these swords that's a bad
state bigquery has a background process
that goes and fixes that for you so you
don't need to worry about this to some
extent so even if you don't follow these
best practices right we have this
optimization process for any behind the
scenes that fixes up your data for you
and gets it into a better state so that
your courses and faster as a result
okay so let's transition a bit to the
topic of querying metadata so we
recently released something cool called
information schema views so if you're
familiar with the sequel standard I've
read it probably more than I would like
there's this chapter called schemata so
schemata describes these information
schema Buse that give you a structured
way of referencing metadata in the
system so so far that in bigquery this
means that we include things like
schemata view this gives you data set
metadata we have table related views
there's a view about views themselves
we have columns information and we have
a big for specific extension called
column filled paths that gives you sort
of an overview of the nested data that
you have and we're going to keep adding
more over time so it's sort of a very
quick overview of these so we have these
commodity use and this gives you data
set metadata so in this example I'm
running a query that gives me the
locations of all the data sets in the
speak where a public data project broken
down by region so I can see that I have
four data sets in the EU region and the
rest appear to be in the US region
I have table metadata so I'm able to run
this query over the san francisco data
set for example and see these tables
that have the prefix bike in this case I
have a views metadata tables so this
gives me information about the actual
definition of these views so I can go
run a query and pull the definition of
all the views that I've stored in
bigquery there's a columnist view so
this gives me information about the
column names and their types which ones
are used for partitioning which ones are
used for clustering that sort of thing
and I can go and run a query to figure
out essentially any information about
that I want about these columns we also
have this big query specific extension
called column filled paths
so this list you actually analyzed the
paths to the data themselves so you can
have structs for example in bigquery you
can have a race that kind of thing this
basically gives you a way of sort of
understanding the paths of data that you
can use so in this example I have this
inputs column and outputs column and
both of these have fields underneath
them called value and so I'm able to
figure out that both of those have
numeric type I'm able to analyze that
sort of it that we field level okay so I
have sort of a short example on this so
I'm going to tie all these concepts
together in a query actually if we could
switch the demo that would be great
okay so in this step of what I'm doing
is I'm actually rebuilding the great
table statements that I can use for my
tables so I have a variety of attributes
here so one is that I have this function
for making the partition by expression
for my for my tables I have this clause
that I'm generating so here's the actual
partition by text itself cluster by
clause for any Questor tables I build
the column list itself any options
associated with the table and then I
think these various components and I
combined them all together in order to
generate this create a replace table
statement so what you can see here is
that I've generated these these results
let me zoom out a bit actually so you
can see better so I generated all these
greater replace table statements to
recreate the definitions of my tables
from these columns and I have this
partition by attribute options list
etcetera so okay that's pretty cool you
can also find this example in our public
documentation we added this if you
search for information scheme and we
show you had to do this yourself
though I switch back to the to the slide
deck please okay something else I'd like
to talk about is that we're announcing a
new feature around encrypting PII so
when you manage to PII and bigquery
there's a couple things that I want to
mention first so keep in mind the data
in bigquery is always encrypted at rest
whenever we store your data those
capacitor files that are on disk are
kept in an encrypted format our API
endpoints use HTTPS so clients in
requests as well you can also use CM ek
to encrypt specific tables with with a
key essentially that you manage yourself
if you want to and we provide an API
called data loss prevention they can
help you to classify and redact PII this
was just something some things to keep
in mind basically as I'm talking about
this so here's the problem statement
though tracking PII in your data across
many tables and data sets is hard you
don't necessarily know which columns
have PII or any of the tables
necessarily that have PII it's kind of
hard to track them all down when you
want to remove data for a specific user
what can be hard is to run updates and
deletes across all the tables it's hard
to figure out first of all what you need
to actually run those queries over and
that can also be expensive to go and
modify all those too
so what I'm announcing today is that
encryption functions in bigquery are now
generally available so this is a pretty
powerful feature but it's also very low
level and I want to talk a bit about how
you can actually leverage this in your
applications these are functions for
creating key thuds performing encryption
and decryption in the core use case for
this is crypto deletion of PII you can
keep any PII in an encrypted format and
then you can perform what's called
crypto deletion and I'm going to show
you a bit how that works so how does
crypto deletion help so what you can do
is you can encrypt each of your own
users data with a different key and then
when you want to delete their data
instead of tracking it down across all
the tables that you may have what you
can do is you just throw away the key
you just delete the key and now the data
is no longer recoverable so to set this
up what you can do is that imagine that
you have this customers table for
example and you want to generate a key
for each of your users so you can go and
add a new column to the table and then
you can run an update statement to
actually populate the key sets for each
of the customers that you have so here
I'm using this new key set function and
I'm generating a new heat set for each
of my customers now what I can do is
that what I want to encrypt data using
these key sets I can run a query like
this where I use this ad ad done encrypt
function and what i do is i generate
ciphertext based on that input data that
i have using the using the key set for
each of my customers so now each
customer's data is encrypted using their
own key I can give somebody access to
this customer data table for example
right all the state is kept in cryptid
form and so even if somebody had access
to this without the key sets it's not
readable right there's nothing you can
do with that information because it's
stored in encrypted form I can also
decrypt data using key sets so I can use
this decrypt string function for example
and I can go ahead and recover that data
from that customer data table using the
key sets that I have stored in my
customer table and then as I mentioned
so when I want to crypto delete data so
when I have a number of inactive
customers somebody asks for me to delete
their data etc what I can do is I can go
ahead and delete those those key sets so
once those key sets are gone I don't
have a way of getting that encrypted
data back right I have to use those
decryption functions in order to decrypt
that data and so once those key sets are
no longer available to me I can't
recover it at that point so what's cool
about this is that you can perform
encryption outside of bigquery too we
have interoperability thanks to the
library that we use so we use this open
source library called tank there's this
thing in the industry that you should
never roll your own crypto we didn't try
to make that mistake in bigquery we use
an open source library it's developed by
security engineers at Google so we have
pretty high confidence in this so we use
this library called tink and what this
lets you do is that you can not only use
these functions within bigquery itself
but you can also use them in whatever
applications you build outside of
bigquery too so you can create key sets
perform encryption decryption etc either
within your own key within your own code
or with in bigquery directly so imagine
you have a scenario where you can
encrypt using dataflow for example and
then decrypt using bigquery so any data
stored in your tables the stored in
encrypted form but you encrypted it
using data flow and you can do that
because tank is available as an open
source library and use them from
dataflow or whatever other application
that you're building alternatively maybe
you store your key sets on cloud storage
and your encrypted data in bigquery
so maybe you don't want to keep the keys
in bigquery itself for example you want
to keep them on files on cloud storage
what you can do in that case is you can
define an external table over your cloud
storage key sets
and then you can run a query that joins
the data between that key side table and
the encrypted data that you have in
bigquery and that gives you away a
performing decryption in bigquery
without ever having to keep the the key
sets themselves stored in bigquery
metadata okay so finally I've got a
couple of cool things to announce these
are alpha announcements so as you may be
familiar alpha alpha features are not
available for anyone to use we have
specific programs around these so if you
want access to one of these please talk
to whoever your Google contract is
whether it's a sales person or a
customer engineer etc and they can help
set you up with access to these this is
sort of an early preview of some
upcoming features that we think that
you'll really like the first of these
that I'd like to mention is our
scripting alpha so scripting gives you
the ability to send multiple queries and
one request to bigquery it also lets you
use variables and then furthermore you
can use conditions and loops to actually
manage the flow of execution of the
script that you send to bigquery so this
is a really powerful feature right
historically we've only supported
running a single query at a time in
bigquery so this lets you build a lot
more functionality into bigquery
directly where you just hand us the
script of all the things you want to
accomplish and we go and run it for you
and again if you want access to this
please talk to whoever your Google
contact is about enrolling secondly
we're announcing the alpha persistent
UDF's so there was just a comment on our
public issue tracker this morning it's
been two and a half years since somebody
requested this feature why haven't you
done this yet well here it is so we have
this alpha now you can come and try it
if you want to it's been a long time in
the making but it's finally here so if
you've ever wanted to reuse functions
across different queries or maybe
somebody has created a bunch of
functions and wants to share them with
you you can now create them and then
share them with anybody that you want to
so this gives you a way of reusing
functions instead of having to put them
all at the top of your of your queries
now okay and so with that that's the end
of my section
please welcome super to the stage from
Home Depot
[Applause]
thanks idiot
most of the features mentioned are
really game-changing here good morning
y'all I'm super excited to be all before
you my aim is to talk about some of our
experiences in implementing a enterprise
data warehouse on the Google platform
have an agenda here talk a little bit
about the Home Depot cool cool
interesting facts switch to enterprise
data warehouse which is my group here
and then we touch upon the facts and
dimensions before I'm going to speak
about the challenges I'm very sure
everyone has shopped at Home Depot we
are big we are the number one home
improvement retailer in the world we
have 153 distribution centers and we
have a we are like a hundred billion
dollar sales my group specifically the
enterprise data warehouse we started the
journey to implement our enterprise data
warehouse on the bigquery sometime
around 2016 today we have close to 16
petabytes of data as we speak we are
still growing actually we have 40,000
users across the stores corporate
centers the distribution centers and
also we do a lot of mobile reporting and
analytics on the mobile TV devices right
I'm very sure everybody knows here start
schema the intent is to show what it
means to us as Home Depot with all the
5000 tables that I mentioned if I draw
out this diagram I am very sure it'll
cover most part of the wall behind me
but as a simplicity here what I am
trying to show you is we have like sales
we have orders and supply chain customer
orders the classic retail dimensions
like the product the vendor the stores
and
customer obvious touch upon like a
minute to talk about what facts are the
facts means metrics or the measures some
BI tools talk about transactional in
nature usually they could be streamed
they could be in batch and other
important thing is they couldn't
additive example sales can be rolled
across weeks or time or a tragic thing
is inventory is a snapshot you cannot
roll it over time expired
here master data comparatively they're
smaller in size they have attributes
example is queue size right and nailed
in her a screw in Home Depot could be
3/8 size inch or 1/4 inch size there's
changing right they change over time
right and they're hierarchical example a
organization hierarchy could have like a
location moving to the district all the
way up to the division also here the
primary purpose of all the dimensions
here is to slice and dice your facts
right and then to do drill up and down
the OLAP functions as we call challenges
right I know as we are implementing
enterprise data Vera's on any platform
for that matter there'll be tons of
challenges numerous and yeah I could
spend like pretty much the whole day are
talking about these but to the because
of interest of time I was a narrow the
scope to just the dimensions right and
also touch upon a few of these you know
whenever we are implementing awareness
especially in the data integration space
we want to find out like hey what has
change in the source and to a delta
processing right that's one and this is
a big deal and pretty much all the
businesses I guess from a business
perspective we want to talk about Aziz
was as as was reporting I will explain
what that is in the next slides and the
other other thing I want to touch upon
is
versioning right how do we store history
well most of the points are interlinked
one key thing are they again I want to
mention it is about Sergey keys one of
the lessons learnt with the attachment
of data scientist and analysts who can
write their own theories what we have
found is it's better to avoid like
surrogate keys they are very 1999 ish or
to the early 2000 right it confuses them
because you have to now use surrogate
keys to do all the joints it's good for
operational reporting but not for deep
analytics that's the lesson we learnt
change data capture right I'm very sure
we have a lot of everyone every company
as lot of sources from which we extract
the data some of the sources like
especially with respect to legacy it
doesn't have a method to know like what
has changed
there's no timestamp column to know like
what has changed right that's one
scenario and there are other other cases
where the source as a last update
timestamp which you can use to extract
writer for the Delta processing the
third there are sophisticated systems
where they like example with database
replication they can tell like hey these
are all the changes that you have you
have and that makes life easier in data
integration space as is versus as was
reporting reporting it's a big deal
actually if you look from a business
perspective in the home depot right as I
mentioned in the earlier slides the
dimensions are hierarchical they change
over time they could be slow changing
but they didn't they change over time so
most of the businesses they want to see
all the metrics analyze all the metrics
to the current point in time the most
recent hierarchy example ask you move to
a different department right and they
want to see all the sales rolled up to
the department right what it means right
I'm very sure a lot of companies do
build aggregates for you know
performance to ensure single version of
the truth all the aggregates need to be
restated we call that internally in home
deposit recast so every day we recast
all our matrix to the most recent
hierarchy right but there are the
business analysts and you know data
scientists especially in the legal
departments and the marketing who want
to see all the metrics to a particular
point in time that's you have to go back
like the example give me my sales as of
the hierarchy in twenty two thousand
seven or give me the address of the
customer when he was in as of 2010 right
to do that yet enable as was reporting
to do all these you need to keep the
history that's the point here I guess in
the next slide this slide is multifold I
want to talk I know I put as one of the
methodologies for versioning to
implement our history but I'm also going
to talk about our home depot methodology
here of how we do data integration with
the ELT approach right on the third
point I want to also make here is I
talked about a use case where the source
does not tell me what has changed so I'm
going to go through that use case two in
this slide right going from left to
right we have the source table right it
could be mainframe it doesn't have a
last update timestamp so our integration
methodology in the data ingestion is to
extract that into a raw data set when I
say raw means so similar it's pretty
much close to what sources right and
then we have to scrub the data so we
scrub it to be using lookup so there are
a bunch of bigquery functions that that
we can use to scrub the data and then
land it into your staging database again
this is a elt we load into bigquery and
then do all our massaging of data
they're right and then the third point
now the data is pretty much what we need
I guess right but it does I said the
source didn't tell me what has changed
it has all the rules so now I'm going to
go to my yesterdays copy or the previous
runs copy of my target to a full outer
join to figure out what has changed
right if it is in the source but not in
target that means they're new rows if it
is in target but not in in the source
that means something has got deleted if
it is in both and the columns have some
difference that means they're they're
updated right we take up all these
changes stack them up in a table which I
am calling it as change change capture
table right and if you see that's in the
in the data data set so we have a raw
which is so similar we have a stage
where it is temporarily massaged and
then the final is all in the in the data
data side the other thing is now we have
to do the Aziz was as as was so to do
the Aziz use bigquery functions like row
over right there are analytical
functions to get the most recent row and
put it in the target which is our be
exposed to business right I didn't
represent the as was case but you could
always use the analytical functions like
lead-lag all those functions and get to
like effective begin and end dates and
do the as was reporting right one thing
to point out here is from our legacy
warehouse to which we move to bigquery
we do a one-time conversion right and
how to put the data into the target the
same thing what I did is I explained
using the data here and now one thing I
want to point out is there's an active
flag so if a record is caught deleted we
make the active flag as false
moving on pros pros of this approach
it's very easy to implement and it's
self-healing you basically stack up all
the changes let's say if a transaction
some transaction comes late you could it
still goes in and self heals right
because there's nothing much getting we
are stacking up on pulling the latest
the it works for even a stream data
though my example said that I am doing
like a full extract this this this
approach works beautifully well for for
the streaming cons one of the cons I
heard from business is if they are not
that sequel savvy is you have to use
some analytical functions to get to as
was but to mitigate it we could always
create to pre create the tables and
expose them right and then if the tables
are huge I know sometimes the customer
dimension could under similar dimensions
could be a multi million two billion
records there might be some performance
issues if you are joining to really a
multi billion fact table that's one
thing to get keep in mind the next
approach again this slide is also multi
fold here I've used streaming use case
but it could work even for a batch it
has for representation I put the
streaming moving from left to right in
this case the source is sophisticated
and by the way these are live examples
that we are running in our warehouse the
source is sophisticated they use a data
replication technique technology to
identify give me all the changes
including they say these are inserts
these are update and these are deletes
and we use a transfer process to put it
on to the pops up from this point v1e be
a zdw all this data now right so again
sticking back to our comfortable
methodology enterprise data warehouse
metrology here is to put it in a row we
use data flow
to put it into our raw database with all
these changes from that point you know
we we do have a bunch of transformations
because we are following the ELT
approach here we could do some in the
pubs or but for these very especially
using ELT reason being our technical
staff are really familiar with the
sequel or existing earlier legacy
warehouse had a bunch of sequels to do
the ELT so it was seamless for the
development for faster development right
we put it into the staging and then we
used the bigquery merged DML statements
which I believe was launched around a
year ago I I think so so once this was
done most of our tables now use this
merge statements with the effective
being onion dates already in the table
right next slide the same thing I
explained this example with data here
pros and cons right compared to the
other one the pros you know the
effective begin and end date is already
in the table and you could do do that as
was and Aziz type of reporting's easily
using the effective begin and end dates
right it worked if what we have found is
if this approach works well for tables
with like I think we have a couple of
dimensions with our billion records both
with 80 columns and it still works well
right
the cons right it's slightly complex
right stay in stacking we just stack it
up and pull the latest whereas here you
have to do the take care of some some
level of programming here and then the
second one when we are doing streaming
it it adds a different level of
complexity here reason being you have to
now use effective begin and end time
stamps rather than dates it it adds
a slight layer of complexity what we
learnt right so obviously there are a
lot of challenges with with when a when
you are doing a data integration right
in in a big enterprise data warehouse
space right we are using the e-elt
methodology because bigquery has all the
rich functions and still I haven't found
something that we cover here that is not
available in bigquery that we cannot use
the Klan's or data pretty much right we
use this approach to to do our data
integration and it so far is working
well and we migrated like more
integrated close to 5,000 tables in less
than a year hey spring is finally here
right it's it's time for yard work and
you know mulch and right I would
encourage you know stop by your local
Home Depot store very soon one of my
co-worker there will help you thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]